[Music]
what Italian immigrants came to America
meat became a staple their money
stretched further than before
repos became larger in size and required
less bread than their Italian villa
let's hoof it takes
they were then combined with additional
Italian foods to create this Holy
Trinity while the exact origin of a
fortune cookie are no historians agree
it is an American invention while some
say David Jung founder of Hong Kong
noodle company in Los Angeles was the
original creator others say the treat
was first made at Bank Jana a bakery in
San Francisco is served by Makoto
Hagiwara of Golden Gate Park Japanese
tea garden
Samuel German pay the type of bacon
chocolate named German sweet sharpen in
1852 over 100 years later in 1957 recipe
for German sweet chocolate cake was
published in the Dallas Morning News
using Samuel Germans baking chocolate as
a recipe of the day General Foods which
owned the baking chocolate saw the
popularity and distributed their recipe
[Music]
two companies in the US have claimed
inventing the tortilla chip jose
Bartolome Martinez owner of semolina
milling company in San Antonio Texas
claims to have created the chip first
Rebecca Webb Carranza is often credited
as well after she began find pieces of
misshapen tortillas and her family's
fryer
[Music]
the exact origin is Murphy as
cuban-americans from Tampa and Miami lay
claim to the sandwich
[Music]
in Tampa thousands of Cuban immigrants
settled in the 1800's to work in the
cigar industry however you eat the
sandwich in the United States today is a
modified version of Cuban recipes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you